nothing that why did this young warming  act white I'm not very black I was on  welfare start with nothing you know I  got a little bit of something I'm gonna  bright screen videos make you feel me  that's why I'd like this cuz I'm on with  a crack addict nothing you feel me funny  mom you an act now 30 South Central I  just I just want to be more culture  around the world cousin that Grover  I just wanted swag you know I want to be  cool you know you sound like 80 I just  want to be like you alright I want to be  black alright Chuck we are my little  cousin up Goodman dose of life in the  hood so you treat him like you treat me  welcome to the set then little homie  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  did you listen you can be killed on you  yes I do I'm like you man's food we are  you never like it's like a music video  Cody going to grab a soda be like the  best thing in the world you know what I  say  [Music]  you